He's a mafia boss. That's how he thinks of this. Hey, I've got
like a rat in here who's who's decided she's she was in my confidence.
She turned on me. Everything else stops until this is
We've got these two things, I think. Oh, man. They both fit.
They both fit a little bit. Trying to think of what I want to
go to first. I might do this. Maybe review some episc covering
the right-wing Civil War stuff.
>> What is the word? expressed in diverse
So this civil war
is on the grounds of who gets to assume or who ought to assume
the mantle of Trump post Trump. That is where I think the energy
is coming from. People are we are almost a year into this. What
[music] happens
Tucker Carlson has on Nick Fentes
groperism has break has broken containment. It has started to
>> It has broken contain. Oh. Oh.
Oh, that's cool. I hope I listen. Am I I know Pisco is a viewer.
Okay. I know he is. I know he understands my I know he understands
that I can give insight on this. It has broken containment. That's
the That's the exact metaphor.
Not matador or mettor. It's the metaphor we've used here, right?
Breaking containment. He's like an SCP. You can't let him get
out cuz he's going to be like a mind virus. He's going to work
his way through everybody. Okay. Who be noticed more and more
by everyone. It is national news.
I think that the rise of corporism has been underestimated in
the last years. I mean, I've been seeing um shades of it and
even among the people I talk to. I because I watch Fendis' show.
I see what he talks about and I see the way
people will mimic
and he says that there's at least a ch at least a chance he gets
it right. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, dude. It's I think you are a total
[__] if you never watch your like enemy content.
If you if you're like a political influencer, you don't watch
the other side. You're trying to like get your you're trying
to, you know, make some political headway. You have no idea what
the other side says or thinks. You are a [__] You
[__] suck at your job. Anybody who's just like, "No,
you don't watch that stuff. It's gross. Don't watch it. They
suck. They're They're like total
>> and take his views on and even just the way they talk
about certain things or >> this is what you did. Yes. This
is exactly what I did. This is the crime for which DG labeled
me anti-semitic was precisely what Pisco is talking about right
here.
That's uh it's very funny, very >> the words they use.
I've kind of tuned in an ear for for hearing that kind of stuff.
And so some of you have been like because they've noticed I've
been like do you follow? I said that like in multiple conversations
I've had with right-wingers who I bring on and I'm almost always
correct because I hear something and I'm like that sounds like
a gripism. That sounds like a fantism.
So what's the problem with the GOP and MAGA? The problem is
he's going to do the he's got to do the Hania stuff, right? The
problem is that in the same way that Trump will catch knows that
he can't disavow like this rampant national rampant nationalism
even white nationalism from Fuentes without losing a significant
block right and the GOP broadly knows this that you have to be
careful with what you disavow from Nick and Nick's like consistently
put these wedges in and he's built like this uh almost set of
dominoes where now if you want to disavow white nationalism that
tips into another domino and you're disavowing you know you're
disavowing you know being anti-immigration and that tips into
another domino and another domino and another domino, right?
Until if you want, he's basically set it up so it's like if you're
going to disavow Nick Fuentes over Israel, then you're disavowing
like the entire America First movement. It's it's like it's a
part of how MAGA has evolved over time. And it's like trying
to call out Nick even for his most heinous views is going to
set off like chain reactions.
Groper ideology and Grier sentiment
and this irony poisoned
kind of
outlook sort of
power analysis informed by
cynicism, snark. I don't mean that they're telling the truth.
I mean that they're that they have the veneer or at least the
understanding what they're doing is they're telling hard truths
that this style, this viewpoint, this emerging tradition. >> By
the way, with Pisco's pausing, I literally have this at 1.5.
By the way, it's so crazy seeing the difference between Pisco
debating or talking on Lib and Learn and just blocking through
his thoughts on his own stream.
Like I have to slow him down to one on Lib and Learn because
he's he's talking so fast to not get interrupted during a debate
and he'll keep talking the whole time so that he doesn't get
interrupted at all and he just goes and goes and goes. But now
we're watching like this his own thoughts. He can just slowly
work through it and it's like I have it a 1.5 and it's almost
too slow tradition which by itself is not novel in the American
history. Like we've had nivists before, we've had the Pat Buchanan,
we've had
you know these types even in the early 20th century etc. But
this iteration of it has actually convinced a lot more people
than maybe they thought.
It was easier to deny I think for them
they could write him off as being this person this platform person
who no one is willing to talk to.
But after Charlie Kirk's death and where Charlie Kirk
there's there's a critical breakthrough that happens after Charlie
Kirk's death, which is you lose your ability to network with
Charlie Kirk. If you talk to Nick Fuentes,
but you also that no longer is an issue when Charlie Kirk is
dead. Okay, they've lost their ability to network with Charlie
Kirk now. And that was really the thing holding conservatives
back, which tells you a lot about the MAGA movement, right?
Uh yeah, it tells you a lot about the manga movement
back from collabing with Fentes
before this uh basically from We Control Your Bodies right after
the election and and just he's been on a steady trajectory upwards
since then. was a focal point, a magnet for a lot of the energy
from youth people and where he even he was dealing with a lot
of the gaper stuff and you could hear him start to to adopt a
lot of the positioning that's more skeptical of traditional conservatives
I don't know conservative views more skeptical of Israel even
though even though I don't think he I don't buy this
you guys are somebody told me Pisco really understood this he's
not doing horribly he's doing better than most conservatives
okay have done but I don't so Charlie Kirk didn't get pressured
to adopt their positions he basically had to take positions that
were adjacent so he could continue to like have some of his other
stuff right. He was always going to stick on Israel
and he kind of only got rendered wrong on Israel by the you know
October 7th attacks the ground operation into Gaza but like all
of the other stuff he got moved a little bit but he just had
to move back to kind of standard what bog standard conservatives
would have believed 10 years ago. I don't think I don't think
the Gropers could chase him that far. But they did chase him
off of like some of the more progressive conservative positions
like trying to be friendly with the LGBT community. They chased
him all the way off of that. Okay. What's the other one? Immigration.
They chased him pretty far away in immigration, too. Like he
was he was pretty open immigration. He was pro H1B. He was pro
a bunch of stuff. And they kind of chased him back to being more
nivist.
But other than those two positions, I think Charlie didn't get
moved a ton.
>> Yeah. Owens narrative that he was about ready to like
throw Israel out or
once he died
and
you don't really have a good replacement that's willing to play
ball with the people currently in power.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Nick Fent is not the replacement
for Charlie Kirk. Nick Fentes was a movement unto himself. He
had a ton of cultural viability within the young parts of the
GOP, the only parts of the GOP that were young, right? He's the
He's like the number one influencer there. Way more, I think,
way more than Charlie Kirk. Okay, you could talk about like when
he go when Charlie Kirk goes to a Utah campus, maybe that's a
place where Charlie Kirk has more reach with youth than anyone
else, but Charlie Kirk has been massively lionized after his
death. Nick Fentes in terms of any secular hold on the GOP or
any secular GOP members at all,
he he had a massive share of that.
And
uh it wasn't like Charlie's death in terms of oh now now there's
like this power vacuum. It was it was that Charlie was explicitly
holding back. It's man, there's got to be there's got to be a
good example of this somewhere in the Middle East, right? Like
somebody who's maybe Saddam Hussein actually. Maybe it's a little
bit like that where he's like holding back, you know, the religious
fundamentalists
and then he dies and then suddenly ISIS is taking over, right?
Not so suddenly, but that's it's a similar thing where Charlie
Kirk was the bull work. He he said basically if you platform
this guy, he chastised people whenever they came near him. He
chastised people for platforming him. He would not say the name
of the gropers. He would not say the name of Fuentes, right?
He wouldn't give them anything.
He was the bull work. As soon as he was gone and people could
openly like platform and network with this guy who had thousands
and thousands of viewers, they did. So
Erica Kirk isn't
going to cut it. A lot of these young I mean the gender divide
in terms of political affiliation has never been starker.
So sorry I hate to I hate to crow my own praises again. Okay.
I don't I love doing that actually. But who told you this? Okay,
Erica Kirk ain't got it. I could tell from moment one, she didn't
have what it takes. She couldn't run that movement. She couldn't
stand up. Dude, get somebody else in here cuz she's going to
[__] this up. And it's
Naga is not winning women over.
They need men. If they want longterm, then you >> play
devil's advocate on that. And so they you turn around Charlie
and you realize that more people are starting to interact with
Fenders and then goes on Carlson and now he's everywhere. He's
on the New York Times. He's making headlines
and the taboo has significantly lessened.
No. Again, no. Again, no. Not my impression. Okay. I I actually
can't say for sure that I can't say for sure that Pisco is wrong,
but my impression of this is not that the cultural taboo was
gone. I think the cultural taboo has been gone for a long time.
There was an economic taboo. He was blockaded out. There wasn't
a cultural taboo and there hasn't been since like 2023,
I want to say. It's like after somewhere in 2024, this cultural
taboo had totally disappeared. There was like one guy who you
couldn't talk to. And it wasn't because his beliefs were that
that horrible that you just couldn't talk to him. Tons of people
talked to Lucas Gage. Tons of people talked to that
brain damaged Jake Shields guy, right? It wasn't like the beliefs
were bad. It was the person. And there was only one person who
was keeping everyone away from. That guy died and it was fine.
It wasn't a cultural taboo. It was an economic one. People didn't
want to deal with getting blacklisted.
And Tucker didn't break the taboo. Tucker just decided he was
going to go and talk to Fuentes. And what happened was there
was a bunch of people who went, "Oh, oh, the ball work's gone.
We have to we have to destroy this guy's reputation right now.
It's incredibly important we crush this guy right now. That's
why you see a slew of newspaper articles about him. That's why
you see a slew of pieces because people were freaking out that
oh people forgot how bad Nick Fuentes is. Oh wait, this guy has
like 20,000 live viewers. This guy has like 15 20,000 live viewers.
Oh my god. Oh, we need to tell everybody how bad he is.
Like it it was just the most delayed reaction. They didn't realize
that that cultural thing had been gone for a long time. And they
kept feeding it when Charlie died, too. That's the funny thing.
They actually were just overtly feeding it, right? Oh, actually,
Charlie believed most in like freedom of expression, freedom
of speech. He would debate anybody. So, why should we like not
platform Nick Fuentes? Charlie would debate anybody. Charlie
would debate anybody. Charlie would debate anybody. No, Charlie
wouldn't debate anybody. That was not a part of his his like
belief system. And that's been proven out by Charlie's own friends
leaking messages of him freaking out about other people talking
to Fuentes.
So again, he was the guy with his knee on Fuentes's neck. Once
he's gone, him and Ben Shapiro, once one of them is gone, there's
no nobody holding Nick back anymore.
And this is happening at a time when
our leaders or the MAGA leaders, not our I don't associate myself
with MAGA or with Griers. our leaders
or MAGA's leaders, sorry, I said it again,
are having to figure out where to go next. So, there's this fight
for relevance in terms of who the not just young people following
this guy,
who is their fire brand, who they want to model themselves after.
And online,
the non-Griper types are losing that
Uh, [screaming] I think Andrew Wilson's making a lot of headway,
too. Andrew Wilson's clearly making a lot of headway, but it's
like an age split. If you're 35 plus, if you I think it's I think
it's closer to 40 actually, there's like a massive
a massive audience for Andrew Wilson, right? Andrew Wilson is
making money hands over fist. Hand over fist. He's like one of
the top five super chatted people in America,
right? What's Andrew Wilson's take on Israel? It's just a pure
uh non-interventionist
take. Don't don't give money outside of America. He's just that's
his foreign policy, right? He's just a Yeah. Yeah. Not interventionist
foreign policy.
Um I think it borders on being I don't think he's like pro Palestine
or anything. He's just he's one of those people who he could
have like a pro Palestinian opinion. He could have an anti-Semitic
opinion, but all he's willing to say is I just don't think we
should send money to other countries.
Andrew Wilson will submit to Nick. I
I don't know. We'll see.
We'll see.
He gets paid a lot, but he's still like five sub 5K concurrence.
No. Uh I think on some of his like normal streams a lot more
and he's got a different kind of coverage. Fentes is is nice
for people because Fuentes I originally wanted to do a stream
that was kind of like Fentes's stream. I fill up time in some
ways. I wanted to do like a highly produced two hours was what
I wanted to do and then I wanted to go from like the highly produced
two hours of like these are the stories I want to do to like
panel after that. If I had like a lot of money, if I could pay
to like get people to come on panels and do that stuff a lot,
I think not pay to get people just get pay to get like a booker
to do panels and stuff, I think I would do like sort of the old
format of the stream where people would drop in. I'd do something
like that, but for the first two hours, I'd pick like one story,
do a main story, and go like deeper on it, spend time producing
it. Um, I like the panel stuff, too. I'm sitting in the open
channel. It's just like a lot of the people who used to come
around
don't
uh I should probably just reach out to people. That's I'm just
not good at reaching out to people when it was when other people
would reach out to people. Um
when I'm say when I say panels I don't mean like that cam. I
don't mean like a panel for sure. I meant like more drop in more
impromptu
less like you know aggressive.
But we'll see. It's not about organizing panels in that way.
Uh, what the [__] am I trying to say here? Okay,
so yeah, I just want to do the more produced stuff.
Yeah, I like that too, Missy. I like that too. I should probably
just ask people to come on more. Ask them like
I think if I had a way to check availability of people, too.
You could like plan around it a little bit. Think how I want
to do that cuz I'm not I don't have bad connections with like
almost any of those people. I have like good connections last
I've seen. So, I think I can just go ask people. Honestly, I
didn't think about this, but I also believe that a lot of people
just talk to my old Discord account that's not banned.
[laughter]
um,
no, I don't need an old server. I still have a whole bunch of
people in my server. I just don't know. Like, I didn't message
everybody who's in my server and let them know that I have a
new Discord account. So, there's like some people I just don't
have on Discord
just like personal off-stream stuff that I'm taking care of in
some ways and I'm getting like it's getting finished and I
I have like free time. It's just I don't know how to describe
it. You know when you kind of feel like you have free time but
that free time is like kind of limited and you just spend it
relaxing. I think that's where I'm at. I either need to up the
discipline or I need to finish some stuff up. Probably up the
who message you and get no answer probably think you hate them.
Might be. Oh yeah, more stream time. No, it'll be it'll be less
stream time probably,
right? Not less stream time even. But I need to spend more time
being more deliberate off stream about what the approach is.
It's just like I've direction I want to go with some stuff like
just in terms of you know panels, having people drop in, who
to bring on, what to do, what to talk about. Uh, I've just been
going with like stuff I find interesting and stuff I know about
and then we just do stories around that,
but probably need to do some more deliberate planning
Streamers that can't do 40 hours 40hour weeks are weak. Yeah,
but I do I don't do 40hour weeks. I do like 50 hour weeks, right?
Like I I quite regularly do a very very long streams like multiple
days a week. Bring back Wolf Gang. Wolf Gang's not an internet
guy. All right,
you think I don't want Wolf Gang to come around sometimes? He's
just not an internet guy. All right, he's not hanging out.
They just are.
JD Vance is walking on
I don't want to get involved.
I don't want to get involved in this. They're sitting on the
fence. That's a market shift in position.
Are we going to address the Bubba in the room? Yeah, there's
an email about Bubba or
JD Vance is walking on eggshells
regarding Fuentes.
That should be a signal. Mhm.
Okay, that's good insight.
That is smart insight
that like literally Nick JD Vance won't even say anything.
Yeah, that's good
>> This is relevant.
Yesterday, Trump posts, "Did Thomas Matthew, sometimes referred
to as Rand Paul Jr.
Because of the fact that he always votes against the Republican
party, get married already, died, I think." No, one of the polls
have less than 8% chance of winning the election with a loser.
>> Oh, what? >> And then right after that's rough,
>> of congresswoman in quotes, scare quotes. Marjorie Taylor,
she goes through MG MTG stuff.
I is he going to talk about more? I guess he is he including
this in Civil War stuff? I didn't think of it that way. It is
interesting to think about in those terms. I kind of we ran through
some some dynamics with it in terms of what Fuentes was saying
in that Tucker interview. I wonder if Pisco pulled that >> green
of the great state of Georgia. Over the past few weeks by my
creating record achievements for our country tweet though >> as
well
opposed to Nick Fuentes Griers all that
>> Hold on. So take this from the point of
what I'm trying to describe not from like my own personal ethical
view. I am, I think, concerned, greatly concerned and totally
opposed to Nick Fentes, Griers, all that [__] I think
it's disgusting. I think that their um ideo
>> low human capital, in other words, the term that they
like, Richard, whatever. And so, I'm committed to opposing these
obviously, right? Um, you guys know what I stand for. You know,
I'm never going to be a Roy Bernes ball scratcher.
I'm analyzing this, I think, from a
political calculation perspective.
>> I think this is great for us.
>> Yeah. Obviously, >> I think this is stupid for
Trump
and I think this is a rare opportunity
>> uh he's going to do some like total creative writing
thing and like do some stuff with with Democrats and make some
things. No, it's probably not. >> Why do I think this is
a Let's start with the
>> Uhoh. Let's start with the Nick Fuentes. I think we
actually start with the Trump stuff. Okay.
Why do I think it's a bad move from Trump?
A. Why is Trump doing this? Trump is not doing this because Marjorie
Taylor Green was calling him or because Marjorie Taylor Green
went on the view. >> Epstein Files. >> Why is Trump
doing this? Trump is doing this because of the Epstein Files
vote. >> He's piss. >> Now, now we'll have to see
what Pisco updates with. Right. If we watch this,
if Pisco updates tonight, I I I want to see how he looks at it.
Uh, when is Kelly coming back on stream? Never. We don't like
Kelly.
Kelly's not ever coming back on the stream. I mean, not in any,
you know, normal capacity.
It's off about that. That's why he's doing it.
Like, could possibly review content maybe like a friendly way.
He's not doing it because Marjorie Taylor Green is an insane
QAnon person which she is
in some ways. >> I should probably just like follow that
question with timeouts from now on to be honest because it just
gets kind of annoying to answer again and again. Um from this
point on I'll just do one day timeouts if that question gets
answer uh asked. If you ever want to just exit, you can throw
like one day escalating after a while >> or like knowingly
grifting than merely delusional. But she talked about space lasers
as well. She talked about all sorts of crazy
and Trump could have dropped her for any of that stuff if what
was motivating him was like lunacy. Right now, Marjorie Taylor
Green has made a couple comments that might have rubbed him the
wrong way, but she's voted with him almost on everything. She's
taken some anti-Israel votes, but she's done that for years now.
She's backed off the Q stuff. She said a couple stuff about like,
you know, but always whenever she's making some comment on the
cost of living or whatever, it's always coupled with and this
is all the Democrat's fault, which is, as I understand, to be
like the Trump talking point, which is, yeah, maybe I know that
Trump recently sounded worse. Like, there's not even a cost of
living issue at all. Like, why do you guys [__] complain
about this? Totally out of touch, whatever. But how I viewed
Marjorie Taylor Green is she was a useful MAGA person.
>> Yeah, we've covered it >> for Trump to lean on
and he didn't much care about her vote. That's what would be
interesting to watch later tonight is if Pisco how Pisco changes
his calculus here cuz this is what I thought. It looks really
bad when you're doing the
So, Pisco could have
spoken on that reversal cuz I think it changes a lot of this.
It's very it's a very weird reversal. Makes no sense to me. It
makes me think like Trump got an agreement from somebody to get
him out of those files. like somebody's agreed because to the
extent that there was a party line on her
anti-Trump whatever or
thinking the status quo is okay she was following the line of
but Biden did it Democrats did it you know she was never venturing
into I don't like Trump she did not draw first blood on Trump
no one can say well except for the epsene vote right potentially
but she was never and even on the epste vote she was clear in
all of her statements that like I don't think Trump did anything
did anything wrong I don't think Trump this or that so she was
walking that path that some of these types have to say, "Hey,
I want this outcome, but I would never betray Trump. I'm not
anti-Trump." She did not draw first blood. That is what people's
perception is that she didn't draw first blood.
So, when you come out against Marjorie Taylor Green, right after
she is one of the votes, the needed votes to get to the district
edition, and she's talking about these stuff,
what is the immediate
I mean, this is obvious. I I hope there's some more stuff here.
>> Sorry. It's just It's very obvious. It's the Epstein
files. Yes.
Fact number one, he is Let's >> Oh, he's been tweeting.
That's why he's going through this whole thing again. I see.
I kind of was hoping we'd lean this back into
Oh, man. Maybe I should have been a little different congressional
sense
Or like, you know, Governor Baker in Massachusetts when he was
the Republic Republican governor. He's like New England Republican
types. Usually state offices, not so much congressional, the
congressional federal republic has been a lot. So the best case
scenario is enforcing a pressure that was already you already
assumed to have the power you was already assumed to have. And
part of that power is not just and then there comes a moment
when if enough people are able to undermine that perception the
power itself goes away
and that there comes a moment when if enough people are able
to undermine that perception the power itself goes away.
>> So there's a big risk here which is in the in the short
term both happen but in the midterm that is coming up succession.
That's why family often binds these monarchies together. He losing
the keys right? If you don't have a plan of succession, then
your keys to power need to make their own plans for the future
to retain their treasure.
>> Oh god, is he doing
he's doing CGB gray? Okay, >> I talked about this last
time, but I'll mention it Basau um after I do this little monologue
thing. Yeah, we can talk about that for a little bit as
by not choosing a successor, he's adding to the anxiety and this
penting frustration and uncertainty about what to do. It it's
encouraging people to take advantage where they can get them,
including if it suits them, which now it will for MTG
to in the back. But when he when she stabs him in the back, it
won't be perceived that way by her key to power, which is the
Republican electorate.
Oh. Oh, he's I mean, this could be a way she sees it. This is
just totally incorrect, though.
Um, this is this is completely incorrect
because let let me be honest with you. The rep the only part
of the Republican electorate who likes MTG are the pure Trump
sickants, right? That's who likes MTG. That the idea that there's
this like, you know, I we used to talk about the critical theory
stuff, how there's a bunch of the Republican party was bound
together by this idea that a global
like runs the world. I don't believe that that's actually the
case. I've I've leaned way out of that cuz clearly these people
don't give a [__] about that as much as MTG is trying
to stand on it. I think way fewer of those people exist than
we really thought. It's really just sick offense of Trump who
voted for MTG and she happened to be in a superstat district
for Trump and I think she's going to find all of her political
capital disappears. She is not unique in terms of what she says
for messaging. She's not unique in anything except being the
biggest Trump suck with the hardest punch in Washington. Okay?
who's willing to say or do anything to make sure that this guy's
like opinion is put out there and defended. That's like what
she's been known for forever.
She doesn't have another platform. She doesn't have anything
else she's going with. That's like it.
Uh Queen for the raid. That's it.
I I really fully disagree. Okay. I fully disagree that this is
that this is like her strategy. That this is what she wants to
do.
I don't know. I I I
get the idea that she could maybe have somebody who cares about
her beyond this, but I I don't think that's happening, man. I
don't think so. I don't think so, dude. It will be seen as her
defending herself.
Oh, should I go
and if she's one of the loudest voices?
[__] I Okay, I didn't want to do this cuz we went
forward and it's kind of spoilers, but I'm going to go back to
where we were before, okay?
And I'm going to watch from and I disagree with pieces of it,
but now if I'm disagreeing with that stuff at the end, I should
watch this stuff as well. >> And that there comes a moment
when if enough people are able to undermine that perception,
the power >> got and watch the whole thing. I wanted to
skip through and just cover like the GOP civil war, the Tucker
Fuentes stuff, but he's gonna try to tie this this Marjgery Taylor
Green thing in in a deeper way and I should actually follow the
whole thing away.
So there's a big risk here which is in the in the short term
the votes already happened but in the midterm that it's coming
up plan words
if they are able to survive their primary challenges
it shows that he's not all powerful with her federal candidates.
>> I just I don't know what what universe do we think that
her her district cares more about her than they do Trump.
And so that's bad for Trump. Why play if the best case scenario
is just to
enforce a power that everyone already assumes that you have?
Everyone already assumes you're the kingmaker
because the risk is it goes bad. But beyond that, like
before when he had this gambit,
the Magabase was actually with him on the underlying substantive
issue. Trump and not Liz Cheney on Jan 6. Magabase is with Trump
and not Mitt Romney on the impeachment stuff.
>> Pisco is going Pisco is going to he's going to die in
the critical theory hill.
I don't
I don't think these people have principles, dude. I don't think
that's how this works.
I suspect that it will be fine that Marjgery you're going to
see a whole bunch of people by the way.
Oh, how do I explain this? None of the people around Trump have
had the calculus for them significantly changed by Marjgery Taylor
Green's defection. Okay? Everybody who's supporting Trump is
going to watch Marjgery Taylor Green defect and they're going
to attack her. She needs other people who are willing to defect
with her and other than Thomas Massie who's always been defected.
He wasn't really ever a part of this whole group. Who else is
going with her? Is she going to get any of the media personalities?
Is Sean Hannity coming out and saying something nice? Is Greg
Gutfeld saying something nice? Is Nick Fentes saying something
nice? Is Tucker saying something nice? Is Candace saying something
nice? Is who's saying something nice for Marjorie Taylor Green?
Who's going out on a limb to support Marjorie Taylor Green in
this
Nobody. There is no shot Tucker defends her over Trump in this.
He will be silent on this. He might say, "Oh, no. I don't think
Marjory's wrong. I get the
Dude, I I really don't think so." I understand that Tucker wanted
to get Fuentes to join with her.
Oh, if if this was Tucker's play to get Trump out for JD Vance,
I think that's insane. Okay, link me the Tucker stuff. Link me
the Tucker stuff cuz I've not seen the Tucker stuff. Okay,
if if they're going to go No, no, no. Listen, if this was all
some grand plan to get the base to flip on Trump and go to Vance,
it's not going to work. It's not going to work,
I don't think. and those people will come crawling back. I think
he is going to Marjgery Taylor Green and I think he's gonna show
mercy to everybody else. Whatever is going on with Tucker, I
don't know. I don't think Trump's ready to go after Tucker yet.
It seemed like tonight he sort of just let Tucker off the hook
entirely. He was like, "Oh, Tucker can do whatever he wants.
He can interview whoever he wants. I don't care. It's fine."
And then he calls her Marjorie Trader Green.
Oh, man. I think this is totally wrong.
It'll be interesting to see though. It's not one of those things
where I'm like 100% sure. I do I do feel like
uh I wouldn't want to be her
Utah a little bit of a special state, right? One of those cases.
Magabase is with
Trump and not McConnell on whatever was happening and on and
on and on, right? They're with Trump and not Kininger. They're
with Trump and not Jeff Flake. They're with Trump and not
So when whenever he's exercised his power before the MAGA base
is largely with Trump on the substantive issue or the electoral
decision.
>> That has to be the thing though, just so you guys know.
That has to be the reason
like Tucker is going to show mercy to the people who who've shown
they'll break with Trump, right? Not mercy, but um he's like
he's uh what would you call it? Extended an olive branch to all
these people who've shown they'll break with Trump. Fuentes has
shown he'll break with Trump, right? Taylor Marjgery Taylor Green
shows she'll break with Trump. Um I'm trying to think of other
people, but I think he's it's like that. And the idea I guess
there would be something like Tucker wants JD to be president.
Tucker thinks JD says guy. They don't want Trump running a third
term and ruining JD Vance's chance to have like a political career
and have a successful handoff to JD Vance. This is all like JD
the JD Vance kingmakers are coming together. I that makes no
sense to me when you include Fuentes in that
because when when push comes to shove, I think Fentes will always
come back to Trump and
I think the base will always come back to Trump when push comes
to
But Trump is deeply underwater on Epstein with the whole country
and even underwater base by like at least six seven eight maybe
even double digits on Epstein with his own voters
and
So on this issue specifically
whereas the other game and and it's a little give and take, right?
Like
Trump just said tonight, oh yeah, release the files.
Why do we think he's doing that?
When it comes down to it, when it comes down to am I going to
be on JD Vance's team or am I going to be on Trump's
I don't believe it. >> The base and where they're aligned
is largely determined in those previous instance by where Trump
was ates
are defined by Trump's preferences. Then there has been
an like assumption or a kind of locks line with Trump because
Trump's position is what it is. His position being what it is
is a sufficient condition to have the base on his side.
Oh, I'm just saying I'm saying that Fuentes will break away from
JD Vance. That's that's how that's what I know for sure.
He sees JD Vance as like everything wrong with the Republican
party right
>> But these situation is one in which the base is not
on his side. They're not aligned with him.
Marjorie Taylor Green has the easiest response.
She doesn't need to go hard against Trump. So, she's able to
say, "I really respected Trump's vision,
but this is about transparency." I don't know. Why is Trump so
adamant against
Good morning. I want to thank everyone who texted and posted
and commented support for me. You are also kind. I appreciate
love and support. You too. Magnanimous, right?
It's the easiest response in the whole >> Oh, PIC. I just
saw the acronym PIC. I'm guessing people in charge.
Wonder who those people are. Who the people in charge? >> Whole
world. >> And later on she says that Trump lies are coming
out against me. the man I supported all over Epstein.
uh this would be political for both Fentes and you've just described
actually like a total creative writing instance where you have
made up a way their leaders at the same time.
I I don't know what causes people to hallucinate private huff
but is very interesting. You'll have to tell me more. overwhelmingly.
So, she's able to take this this position as
victim and it's all >> JD Vance divorces his wife, moves
away from his kids. It would be so funny. It why? Yeah, but it's
just not consistent. It like like even mentioning it, okay, outside
of like talking about one picture. You're like betraying a total
misunderstanding of who these people
right? I'm just saying you listen, if you just want to skits
post and be like, "Oh, it'd be funny if that happened." It's
fine. But like they'd be betraying the core values that they
have to hold to. None of those people are Trump, right? Like
Fuentes is supporting him there. Well, Fuentes is Trump, but
JD is not. JD has to actually adhere to some values now that
he's out in the open. All about the Epstein files. This is really
it's it's not like this is like hard play to make. I'm not saying
it's a hard play to make, but it's the right play to make. It's
the right play to make to make it all about Epstein.
But you gave her that layup
given the public position and what your frustrations were.
Hold on. Stalin sloth again. JD Vance has people who care. JD
Vance's supporters are people who care. The people who like JD
Vance are the people who buy his whole hill. Those people do
care. People who support Trump are they're in a cult of personality.
Jin form. Okay. Nick Fentes also has a cult of personality. So
he could do whatever he wants. JD Vance doesn't have that luxury.
J JD Vance doesn't have the
>> And the conflation that will happen is if you stand
with Trump on Marjorie,
then you're against the release of the Epstein files
cuz why is Trump attacking Marjorie?
Is Trump attacking Marjorie because she's a creep? This This
totally left out the idea that Trump could just go actually release
the files. I'm gonna kill the stupid [__]
Right. This totally negated the idea. totally missed, totally
misunderstood what Trump would do first. Trump understands, "Hey,
I'm going to fight a onefront war and Marjgery Taylor Green's
trying to flank me while I while I deal with this Epstein file
thing. Marjorie Taylor Green's trying to flank me. Uh, you know
what? Release those Epstein files. Hey, [__]
Hey."
He turns to Marjgery Taylor Green, looks her dead in the eyes.
Hey,
now it's just you and me, [__] What are you going
to do now? I'm I'll release the Epcene Files.
Come at me, [__]
Which is what we saw happen tonight, right? Trump just goes,
you know, release the Epste files. I don't give a [__]
Hey,
>> easy Republican
or cuz everyone really thinks she's a leftist. No one think >> with
who? Who does she survive it with? MTG is a politician. She needs
Trump's endorsement to win in her district. She absolutely does.
She cannot win with the endorsement of Tucker Carlson and Nick
Fentes. that can't lead to her winning her district,
That can't. And and and now she's out in the wilderness. If if
Trump is just going to release the Epstein files, Tucker has
no business like going after him. Fuentes has no business going
after him, right? In his interview tonight, you guys remember,
right? Trump came out. Did he go after Tucker? Did he go after
Fuentes? Nope. Good. And good. Those guys are cool. Those guys
can do what they want. Free speech, all that. Marjorie Taylor
Green. Oh, you mean Marjgery Trader Green? He's gonna this because
that's what he has to do. He always understands. Okay. He's a
mafia boss. That's how he thinks of this. Hey, I've got like
a rat in here who's who's decided she's she was in my confidence.
She turned on me. Everything else stops until this is dead. I
want her dead. I want her kids dead. I WANT THEM DOWN TO THE
GROUND. RIGHT? I can't remember Robert Dairo's rant, but you
know what I'm talking about. like he he wants her gone and he
will he will divert everything to kill this [__]
before he moves forward.
This is exactly why Trump has like tamed that entire party is
this attitude thinks that you haven't sold
your base on why they would be attacking Marjorie. So the only
reason they would be attacking Marjorie the stated reason is
because she should have listened to Trump on the Epstein files.
But the base doesn't agree with Trump on the Epstein files. And
so what has Trump done?
Trump has associated tied
coupled
uh I think this could be true and it could be a total like it
could be totally disingenuous for Trump that he wants the files
released. Right.
>> The Epstein files issue with criticism of Marjorie Taylor
Green.
What did George HW Bush say? linkage.
There's a linkage now.
So, if you take a and say, "I'm with Trump. I'm with Trump. Do
or die. I'm with Trump." And there will be people who do that.
I'm not saying there won't be people who do that. There are people
who will go until the bitter end and say whatever. I'm not saying
they don't exist. But you've made it hard for a lot of other
influencers and politicians.
Now, by the way, now the calculus is different again for all
these people, right? Because if, let's say, this is what's going
to happen. Somebody said Simpson Hoya is saying that Bondi is
going to open an investigation. It's going to block the actual
release of the files. Let's say that happens. Now, you have to
go, "Oh, Trump's just doing this." You have to really turn on
him. You have to get cannibalistic in the Republican party.
I don't believe any of these people I don't believe the Republican
part is in a place where that's going to happen right now. Don't
see it. can't see it
because they rise and fall
on this critique of Marjory
which is ultimately regarding the Epste
So what I think is going to happen is you're going to see a lot
of people ride the fence. Say I like Trump and Marjorie Taylor
Green. We shouldn't be focusing on this. We should
You're going to see people totally revise history. Okay.
I never Wait, you're saying that I said, you know, Trump was
in the Epstein files and he's going after Marjgery? No, I never
said that. I've never said anything like that. I'd never say
something like that. You're going to you're going to see it all
reverse. Okay. Should be focusing on the Democrats.
We shouldn't be focusing on this. We should be focusing on the
great
What do you think JD Vance is going to say? You think he's going
to jump in here? This is fraught with danger.
Because JD Vance does not want to be the person who says
don't release the Epstein files. JD Vance has been doing this
pretense of like yes, Trump is for maximum disclosure. He's in
favor of the Epstein files. So they are going to be clinging
to some other narrative. But I think you'll see more people on
the fence and that chips away to the extent that it's not a uniform
abolishment of Marjgery Taylor Green from the party. It eats
away at Trump's credibility in terms of his strangled of the
Republican party and his status as kingmaker
because there's not a plausible
there's not a plausible right-wing perspective
by which to criticize Marjorie Taylor Green if such a perspective
exha
is there a left is there a liberal perspective okay I because
I've heard some people make the kind of argument where they're
like listen there's a time and a place to this criticism and
it's not in public. Okay, Marjorie, there's a time and place.
We're a party. We're trying to get things done, Marjorie. There's
a time and a place for this and it's not here in public. It's
not on Twitter. Marjorie, you stupid [__]
Cuz I I've seen some liberals do that kind of argument before.
All right.
I could see that happening with
>> Exists. It's on the lines of the classic Republican
party.
Here I'm talking about the pre-term party, which the
Pisco's Pisco is operating on 1.0 software. Somebody needs to
patch him up to 2.0. Okay. All right. You have to deal with that.
Pisco's like, "Ah, I've caught these people in a bind. Based
on their previously stated principles, no action they can take
will allow them to move forward without significant hypocrisy
on their part." It's like, "Hey, Pisco, that's like a 100 different
instances of total hypocrisy on their part that you're skipping
over. They they are they're immune to this. I understand that
you're like, "Yes, I've got them. I've I've won the debate. Okay.
Republicans are immoral. Yeah. I know he knows this. I'm just
saying he's saying there's nothing here and he's probably more
than anything he's probably talking about how he can hammer on
them, right? That's probably what he's saying. He he understands
that they're immoral and and that they're not adhering to any
principles. He's probably just talking about what he can hammer
them on. Party faithful are starting to reject.
Marjorie Taylor Green is a viciferous critic of Israel. She wants
to stop all fun to Israel. So there could be a Republican critique
which is she's not aligned with Israel. which is aligned with
the terrorists or whatever, but that's not where the party's
at or they're not there yet or they're not what they were in
that area. That's not as influential to them anymore. A traditional
Republican critique might be she's in favor of the welfare state.
She's going on the view to talk about why it's important to have
some kind of system where it's more equitable to get healthcare.
Now, I don't really buy that she has any good ideas there,
but
the critiques that would come against Marjorie weren't made contemporaneously
to the supposed sins. And it's not things that the Republican
>> The one thing I will say though is
you can't underestimate how stupid people will get when they
know that they if they f that like
when people see that they're critical to you,
even if it makes no sense, even if realistically you can't, you
know, work with them or something. I'm trying to think of a good
example. Like if you're if you're Oh, uh, actually the best example
is probably Joe Mansion, right? When Joe Mansion learns how critical
he is, when he sees his position as the swing vote on a bunch
of legislation,
he can do whatever the he wants, even if it doesn't make sense.
Even if it hurts like him and the Republicans, and even if it
hurts everybody, he can do whatever he wants. And you you have
to you can't underestimate somebody who's willing to use the
fact that they can hurt you or everybody as leverage, right?
Like, I can keep your legislation unless you give me this. I
can keep your legislation unless you give me that. It's like,
but why would you do that? It helps everybody. Um because I'm
the person who can do it. I'm the person who has you by the balls.
You listen to me now. And you'd be shocked at how often people
will ride that horse all the way off the cliff. Okay? When they
when they know they have some sort of leverage and they think
you they have you over like a barrel, okay? You'd be shocked
how many people will do that and then lose everything. They won't
get anything out of it. They'll go, "Oh, you're unless you give
me what I want." And they'll go, "Yeah, but if you if you do
that, you'll [__] yourself over, too." They're like,
"Yeah, but I don't have anything to lose." And it's always people
with something to lose who convince themselves of that too.
Maybe I'm speaking in too much in in far too general terms, but
I I feel like sometimes there's like, oh, we could all be the
Republican party would be great if it was unified right now.
But because of how that unity is like is powerful,
defection is also powerful. Is does that make sense? Am I describing
something that makes sense to you guys? like like hey when we
don't have two senators break away we can do a whole bunch of
things but that makes those two senators very very very like
you suddenly have to give them more to stick with you. There's
like a balance that happens there. There's like a marketplace
for their vote somehow that pulls them back to going in the other
direction. Like it makes them suddenly they can demand more from
you. >> Yeah. Especially the ideological influencers or
anything actually feel. They don't actually care about that stuff.
They were willing to abide it when it happened. The only plausible
critique is on the Epstein stuff and the unwillingness to bend
the knee to Trump in this specific issue. And a lot of influencers
feel pressured by
the people they count among their coalition. A lot of whom now
are gropers who are trying to exploit
that uncomfortable feeling on Israel and on Epstein and on all
the other kind of populisty issues.
But I don't think you're going to see I don't think you're like
a massive condemnation of Trump. But I think what you'll see
is a slow ebbing chipping away at his power to intimidate
and you're going to see more people sitting the fence and that
undermines his perception lings for themselves.
Yeah, this is I mean it it really is something you could call
the mansion effect, right? Like they can start demanding the
universe from you. They have you by the balls. I if if this coalition
thinks that, right? If the coalition of like Tucker, let's say
Tucker, Marjorie Taylor Green, JD Vance, if they think they have
enough to do just on the basis that like, hey, we're all if these
people sort of like split off and start fighting, so you have
to you have to give us what we want right now, which I don't
even know what it is. The Epstein files, [__] me,
>> that's maybe my issue here is I don't see what I don't
see what JD Vance or Tucker get out of bringing this to a head
right now. I don't see the long-term play at all. I don't get
it. I don't see it. I don't understand it
because if you guys remember a couple weeks ago there's some
there's some paper that's like that Tucker's on the board of
they published an article basically saying like JD Vance is starting
his election campaign for 2028
sort of casting down the idea that Trump will do uh will will
run for a third
it's just positioning
maybe
green American conservative yeah now that Trump has gone nuclear
against
He's in a sense opened her up to like build her own name and
her
gains are necessarily going to come at the expense of Trump unless
they reconcile which after that I don't I don't think it'll happen.
Her gains will be seen as
Trump's losses.
Now it's a zero sum game between Marjorie Taylor and Trump.
Uh, I don't think there's any reason to do advance Carlson ticket
to be honest with you. Critical rad.
Like that's just double dipping in the exact same bucket. Usually
when you pick a VP, it's to shore up some other coalition, some
other coalition member, right? So if they're doing that, you
know, but
I I don't know, somehow they need to get the Zionist back on
their side because they they have this major split coming no matter
what. I don't know. I don't know if the Republican party could
survive two major schisms in like 10 years like that. We'll see.
And if there's someone that Margaret Taylor Green cares about
more than Trump, it's
if she's successful with this vote, if she's successful in other
things, if she doesn't lose her primary, if she gets
that is going to be seen as a significant decrease in Trump's
power.
Why I think this is a mistake from Trump
because this is a particularly vulnerable time for him with the
general electorate and also his base his numbers are going >> oh
the other funny thing here is
to me just pardoning that name San Santos George Santos when
when he pardoned George Santos that was totally ridiculous I
thought he did that purely for Marjgery Taylor Green so it is
interesting that he felt like he was buying her off back then
and now she's still going after It's at a time when you're being
pushed on this Epstein vote and so everyone's going to make that
connection. And it's at a time in which there was already pre-existing
tensions about the future of the party beyond you. And when you're
still doing this kind of like will he won't he run for a third
term
It's it's already adding to the anxiety and lack of certainty.
Trump is unwilling to name a successor. When he was asked about
JD Vance potentially being his successor, he's like, "No, you
remember that? This was months ago.
You guys ever watch the CGP Gray video like rules for rulers?
>> The thing that makes it so that >> that's why
that's why I wanted to get here was uh I I could tell that he
was referencing the CGP Gray video a little bit later and I was
like, "Oh, I have to go back and watch the whole thing cuz I
actually want to understand whatever he's going for here." >> You
don't have certainty in succession. That's why family often >> then
you have a power vacuum. You have a power struggle, not a power
vacuum. You have a power struggle and you start shedding resources
to go towards, you know, fights between these different
>> these monarchies together. He's losing the keys, right?
If you don't have a plan for succession, then your keys to power
need to make their own plans for the future to retain their treasure.
I talked about this last time, but I'll mention it
Basto um after I do this little monologue thing. Yeah, we can
talk about that for a little bit as well
>> in that video based on a book called Rules for Rulers.
Yep.
by not choosing a successor, he's adding to the anxiety and uncertainty
about what to do. And it's encouraging people to take advantage
where they can get them, including MTG
to break with Trump or to him in the back. But when he when she
stabs him in the back, it won't be perceived that way. the post
Caesar situation.
Well, is that equivalent to the post Caesar situation? Like
Octaven was like down. He was selected. He was just too young.
Maybe it is a little similar. No, it's not really that similar.
I don't think
I don't know. By her key to power, which is the Republican
electorate,
it will be seen as her defending
And if she's one of the loudest voices,
>> really think
one, I'm like actually quite upset with myself for not checking
Twitter this morning and saying this. No, no, no. I don't think
this is I don't think this is what's happening. I disagree. But
now I know the answer, right? I've already seen that Trump is
going to focus on her. Trump Trump gets power struggles probably
better than most politicians, I think. like he knows. He knows
when somebody's like truly against him, that person's got to
die. They're not willing to kiss the ring, they got to die.
And he just basically conceded the exact thing.
The exact thing Marjorie Taylor Green had to defend herself because
of. Now Trump's conceded that and he's gone. But Marjorie Marjgerie
betrayed me. Marjorie's a [__] This [__]
h a fire brand. I hate this ter by the way. Fire. They always
use it to rip over like
these upandcomers, right? But she's been around now for four
or so years.
If one of the loudest, strongest voices of your coalition
are saying things that present a break from Trump, they could
actually have influence. And the more that happens and the more
the media media space starts for the Republicans,
again, the power starts to e and e.
That's the Trump perspective. I don't think that Trump thought
about this like rationally.
He's lashing out because he's mad
because that's that's what he's always done. Trump has never
approached things rationally.
Has a hammer
and he's approaching this situation, right? Every every problem
is a nail when your only tool is a hammer. He's just walking
over to a nail and hitting that nail with the hammer,
right? And if it doesn't work, he's going to change the calculus
a little bit and then hit the nail with the hammer again.
He always does this. He always lashes out and just opposes opposes
opposes. And when he goes hard, he goes hard. Y >> sometimes
he does a little poke to be like, I might punch you. I might
punch you. He's been doing a little bit of >> And then
when she didn't move, >> he goes for the haymaker.
>> But I don't think it was a rational choice here. I don't
think that he What is it ever It's It's consistently irrational.
It's been consistently irrational for a long time. Remember when
he as like the party that was all about respecting the country,
respecting the military said, "I like veterans. I like soldiers
who didn't get caught. He like mocked John McCain for being a
and John McCain was like a national hero. He was on like national
TV as the guy who was captured in Vietnam.
He was like the guy who got captured, came back to America, was
an American hero. And Donald Trump went on TV was like, I like
people who didn't get captured. This loser and he he w he skated
through it.
It it's often not made any sense at all.
I don't think that he made the rational choice. I don't think
this is good for
And it's going to, I think, increase the uneasiness in the in
the whispers, if not outright shouts that he has some malfeasants
contained in the files. And if they don't find that in whatever
the DOJ releases,
if they don't find that,
why does this suit Fuentes?
It suits Fuentes because at the same time that Fuentes is making
his case that Trump betrayed MAGA, that Trump is not the answer
cuz I'm going to point me in the direction of where things were
said. So, we just looked at uh Troules.
Oh, Nick. So at a time in which Nick is at a time when Fentes
is gaining more followers never been more relevant going on Tucker
Carlson making the case that Trump is um betraying the movement.
>> Yeah. I just want to point out not that it matters
how smart would Destiny have looked if he just listened to me
when I told them hey the reason the way you should go after Fentes
first conversation they had maybe the second one you need to
point out that he loves Trump even though Trump's the most pro-Israel
president that's ever existed that he it literally undoes everything
about his ideology. He supports Trump. Right. I wanted how smart
would Destiny have looked when he when Nick Fentes eventually
flips back to oh I have to be against Trump because Trump is
so pro-Israel
>> [__]
win >> I mean maybe not I mean I'm glad that he looks like
a for losing to Nick and having no talking points from those
debates at all but
it could have been it could have been good man for liberals everywhere
>> would have done worse things for the country for whatever
reason there would be less confusion about it which I've heard
him say
>> that was I think that was around the time that Dusty
starting to be like super pro-Zionist. And I think he didn't
want to come off as like criticizing somebody for being pro-
Israel. I think that's why he didn't do it. He didn't want to
be the guy who's like, "Isn't it really bad that Trump's pro-Israel?"
He didn't want to look like that. I think >> he's making
this case.
>> And it seems that even if it's not the >> it's
related to what Fentes is saying.
And as between Marjorie Taylor Green and Trump, if the Gropers
start saying Marjorie Taylor Green and if the mainstream Republican
like pundits and stuff start, that's just going to encourage
more platforming of Fentes. Pisco. Oh, I don't know about any
of this. Yeah, I don't know about any of this. Um,
Oh, man. This is going to seem like cope. I think Nick might
be a true Trump believer.
I think if Trump flips on the Israel thing, which is they're
kind of pressuring him towards that. If Trump were to flip on
the Israel thing and sort of like be more skeptical of Israel
in some way, if Nick would flip back to him immediately, Nick
Nick would be like, "That was the only problem I had. Thank God
he's back." I think so.
I don't think Trump will ever do that. I don't think that's possible.
Yeah. Yeah. I don't think that's possible, but I think Nick will.
I think Nick would flip to him immediately. Yeah. Yeah, I think
he's just too integrated, right? I'm
I don't know. I'll have to think about it more. It's one of those
things where I'm almost positive that if Fentes could get plausible
deniability so that he could flip back to Trump, like if Trump
just like if Trump just criticized Israel in a way that was,
but we'll see.
It will start to bring into this focus the even more
and it will cause backlashes even more from the pro-Israel pro
more establishment anti-griber Republican party right
the Mark Leven of the world etc will feel even more compelled
to lash out and to call out and to try to shut down
the gripers so cares literally nobody knows who Mark Leavvin
is
sorry people say people know who Mark Leavvin is in that they
think he's annoying. That's like as far as they know who he is.
They don't they don't listen to his opinion. Nobody cares. >> Like
it's an accelerant to that fire and that of it beyond the civil
war aspect which I don't think you can deny.
Democrats can in the short term really take advantage of this
in the elections.
there's a real opportunity to leverage these internal contraction
and divides. But the danger is that if actually take hold of
the Republican party where the gripers actually take control
of the Republican party because they're like this is not something
we want. But unfortunately when you have incompetent immoral
horrible leaders like Trump, this kind of [__] is
inevitable and there's nothing Democrat. >> Oh, if Fentes
really wanted to win here, he would let people push him out more,
right? I think he would I think he would continue to let himself
be pushed out, continue to infiltrate, continue to let him like
his plan was working and I think
hope I don't know how to put this cuz it's going to sound like
I'm on his side. I swear I swear I'm like more concerned about
him being effective. I think his plan is working to a terrifying
degree. And I think the only thing that can stop his his plan
from working of like I'm just going to continue to be a dissonant
voice. I'm going to let people infiltrate. I'm going to find
people who are passionate. I'm going to continue advocating.
Infiltrate. Don't show your views. listen to me. Infiltrate.
We'll eventually be able to flip this. I think it's terrifying
how well that was working. And I think the only thing that could
stop it is Nick's ego telling him that this is your moment. You
can actually win. You can be the mainstream
Why do you want him to be effective? I just said I didn't
just said I thought it was really dangerous. Yep. But I'm I'm
saying that like I think the I think he probably has too much
of an ego to let this opportunity pass
and I think he's going to continue to push forward and think
like okay I can handle me and
I think he will eventually I think as much as it's he's winning
right now. He's winning culturally. He's winning on the internet.
I think this will get flipped eventually.
One more time. I just But you know what? That might be reverse
anti-semitism on my part. might be reverse anti-semitism because
I just I believe I don't think the getting in a fight without
a Trump card. Okay, they got something around. They got like
the wide They've got like the wide shot of Destiny's apartment
as he sucked Nick off or something. Okay, I I fully believe that
the don't get in a fight without a trump card. Okay, so it's
just my exceptional exceptionalist anti-semitism that's showing
through. I I don't believe they get in a fight with this Fentes
kid without a Trump card. rats can do
to like cause Fuentes or the Griers to lose the Civil War or
to become less like I don't believe there's anything the Democrats
can do to affect it. So like we'll watch another totally true
statement. It does not matter. They don't respect your opinions.
Nobody's going to care if you call somebody racist or like
let's be real. Most Democrats don't see a a huge difference between
Fuentes and like Tucker Carlson or Fuentes and Matt Walsh or
Fuentes and Trump, right? They don't see big differences between
them. Like Democrats don't they can't even like nobody cares
about their opinions on nobody who's in the GOP or or votes GOP
and stuff. And it's I think it's significant. But but I don't
think that that Trump is um thinking about this rationally
and with his own benefit in
Let me see if there's other thoughts I
>> Um they they think there isn't internet ray. There is
there is like tangible differences. There are tangible differences.
There are people who do hold positions that can feel contrary.
Think at some point of his own party, the xenophobia, the all
of this stuff. Ben Shapiro's profited from all of it with his
company, but I don't believe that he's necessarily as fully into
those things as you might think being that he's like profited
from them. It might take his contradictions being laid out, his
like the problems with his business model being laid out before
him for him to make any changes. There are a lot of people who
are like that. They just they don't know they don't know that
they are contradicting themselves. They don't know that they
like the the principles they claim to have kind of fall by the
wayside to other ones. They they haven't run through all those
things. I I think I'm like that. I'm also not even looking down
on those people, right? I I probably have some positions in my
head that don't really make sense.
I don't think I don't think as many people are like fully
on board with the Groper thing as they think. It's just that
basically the gropers are the principles of manga personified
kind of like distilled.
And I think some people don't like that. There's a reason why
the dog whistling and stuff, all of the all of the sort of
pleasantries of MAGA are required. You can't just be like Richard
Spencer or Fuentes. You got to be Trump. You got to be JD Vance.
You got to be something else.
Like I said, I don't expect a bunch of Republican senators and
representatives come say we hate Trump now or even pundits. I'm
not going to do that. I don't think I think what will happen
though is fence sitting and people playing the waiting game and
that will have an effect of its own.
See, Common Good, I respect a lot of Common Good's inputs a lot
of the time. I have to respectfully disagree with this one. I
don't think that these are just young men in their basement anymore.
I think that these are these are people who run in the Republican
circles. They're they're messaging in the young Republicans group.
Like they're they are more relevant than I think people give.
I think that's one of the things that was a cope was these are
just young males. >> The young males a lot of the cult
has pushed into stuff have like extended into having real influence.
But also, you can't underestimate the value of like any subculture
that's totally intolerant of everything else. Um,
Quimman is building his community this way, right? That like
he and maybe it's intentional, maybe it's not intentional, I
have no idea. But when you build a culture where like everything
but what we do is is
gay. Um it makes you kind of toxic, but it also builds up like
this extremely cultlike following that will be totally devoted.
They'll like upvote all of your stuff, right?
Yeah. Okay. So, you can say it's
you really call Quan out. [music] It's not a call out. I would
assume it's intentional unless he told me otherwise, right? But
you build this so that like
it's got different like it's got upsides and downsides, right?
Downside is I don't know what the like
people don't want to collapse is probably like a downside,
but yeah, the upside is like you you force your way into places.
People will be fans of you and will like your ideas because they
don't have their own like internal monologue. you can you can
like replace their internal monologue and they'll they'll start
agreeing with you on things even if they don't want to. You know
what I mean? There's there's like an element of that there. And
I think Fentes has done that in a lot of Republican groups that
these people are like survile. They they don't have an internal
monologue. They're not special. They don't have a spark. And
when they hear Fentes talk or when they hear other people say
the Fentes points and like dismiss their points and just reiterate
the Fentes points enough, those start to like infiltrate in a
way. And I think that's why Fentes gets watched by all of these
older Republican, you know, staffers, older Republican media
makers, all these people, and it just starts to push everything
out.
it's interesting. But you have to you have to consistently run
this thing where like everybody else sucks, everybody else is
gay.
um it's not really about being entertaining. You can be entertaining
without being like that. It's like it's just like a different
thing. And that takes like a very special person to be able to
totally issue like bridges to other people and stuff. Totally
like just be their own like an island onto themselves and to
continue growing through that.
DG kind of turned into that, didn't it?
DG is different. DG is not outwardly like that.
DG is not outwardly like that. They're they're more insular than
that.
I don't know how to describe it. It's it's like they will they
will, you know, on people who disagree with Destiny,
but Destiny doesn't like openly encourage it. Destiny isn't leading
it a lot of the time. Destiny is like too spineless to do that
in most cases.
him leading it. It's like a lot of people around him. It's like
the community basically. If you disagree with them, they'll naturally
go after people. But it's like a little different in that it's
not him being like, "Go and do this. Go and like spread my message.
Go and like make sure it's about me." He's not as overt about
that. I think he he I think he like he probably in their basement.
I think that hasn't been true for 3 4 years,
but feel free to uh >> Also, Destiny is kind of just like
gross. I you can't really do that after you have leaked messages
of you talking about like swallowing that much. It's you kind
of like lose your ability. People you can't infiltrate people's
internal monologue as effectively like normal people. Wait, like
this is gross.
The goal to solving a problem is acknowledging its existence.
And the Republicans for the longest time did not like really
acknowledge the existence of rapers as a significant thing. And
look where that got them.
But that could be lies.
>> Oh, that is true. They
I This is like unironically I love calling it this. They had
this Majino line, okay, of deplatforming
and that Mino line disappeared and it was like a blitz creek
and there was nothing they could do. Like they had this guy off
of everything and then he was allowed on like one or two platforms
and he blitzed through in an instant and made his mark and couldn't
be denied after that. Now they look really bad. There's so many
people who are aware of him that if they cancel him now
that's like another thing where it's just going to be like, okay,
are we going to pretend this isn't like are we going to pretend
that there's not some group in control here? You know what I'm
saying? On the same vein, do you think if proof came out of Trump
blowing a guy or even a horse, do you think that would
uh it depends because I think I now think Trump would just say
it's defaked or something, right?
I don't know. I You can't underestimate the value of like that
cult there.
H maybe it it would hurt probably. Yeah, it would definitely
hurt. I mean like the real spaces that politics is operated in
now. And I I just notice a lot of these conservative, they almost
start to sound like they're paring his talking points a lot of
the time,
>> dude. Ah,
I just regret all of the time not writing down all my thoughts
on this. I would have looked like a sage,
right? Oh, look. Uh, they're all they're all spitting his talking
points. Guess what? That's been them for two years, three years.
They've just been taking from his show. He's been the freewriter
for all of these show. Whoever helps write his show, too. They've
just been writing all these other shows and people just take
Israel. They do find and replace with Israel and they say them,
they Democrats, the people in power, the billionaires, right?
And and they've been find replacing on Fentes' scripts to run
their own for a long time. And now they're realizing that, oh,
we we made this guy like the intellectual leader of our movement
without meaning to. And that's what allowed him to break through
so quickly.
Yeah. Globalists,
secular, transhumanists, all of this, right? her take when we
watch it with Aaron. Um,
who's this uh who's this woman
Amy Dangerfield? Her and even some of Anakica's variance like
I I hear these echoes of Fend's talking points.
So, I think it's becoming significant.
And I almost feel like it's a little bit too late for the Republicans
to do anything. They've alienated
so many other groups of people and they built this like coalition
and inver
I know I know Pisco's watch at least some of my stuff of what
does he has to have like it reminds me a little bit of the you
guys see the Matrix when um >> I wonder if I described
this to him. I used to I used to lay this out in like um the
offline chat or whatever. I used to lay out like these ideas
quite often. So it might be that he just knew it.
Oh man. >> Agent Smith is like unplugged, right? and he
starts using and like infecting the other bots.
So ignore it at your peril Republican party because I think it
is um if there's nothing else to offer as an ideological vision,
right? It's one it's one thing to be like a wrecking ball but
that's not enough anymore.
The coherent vision needs to emerge some some kind of ideological
through line needs to emerge
and Fentus is ideologic. Trump is less so. And so from the ashes,
if there's a vision that's going to emerge, there ought be an
alternative. But no one's been focusing on that, on creating
an
Anyway, that's what I have to say about that.
Lots of people agree, disagree. I'm not telling you that I know
everything. I just in summary, I think it was a dumb move from
Trump
and Cong Shapiro. Shapiro is the person who let this all happen.
Shapiro is a scumbag. >> be on the sidelines and see this.
I'm like, "Fuck you, Shapiro.
You who made the deal with the devil with Trump." >> Why
don't you go to hell? >> Seriously, dude. [laughter] After
what you did and who you supported, I have zero sympathy. On
the other hand, I just
>> dude, it's just a total win. Oh, >> and I think
that they are ascendant in a way that some of these other figures
are >> Call that vibes,
>> but I'm just I've been saying this for
>> He live in Communistia. your opinion is
Um, where was I? Yeah, if you guys want to call in, I realize
I haven't done a lot of or any callins in like the last little
bit of time. How about they both go to help? What up, Liz? I
see you in the comments, by the way. Appreciate